MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Monitoring, analyzing,
and optimizing costs have become
an important part of managing
your cloud environment.
But it can be challenging
to work with all
your cost and usage data.
On this episode of
"Beyond Your Bill,"
we'll look at exporting your
billing data to BigQuery
and how to create
custom dashboards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Our last video covered how
to explore your GCP costs
through the billing reports
that you can easily access
through the Cloud Console.
Now let's look at
exporting it to BigQuery,
and then create a dashboard
using Data Studio to further
explore it.
It's important to note
that these actions can only
be performed by a
billing administrator.
As we mentioned back in the
resource organization video,
you'll want to enable BigQuery
export for your billing account
as soon as possible.
Ideally, you do this as
soon as you create it.
That's because the export
will start collecting data
as soon as you
enable it, and you
can't get detailed billing data
from before it's been enabled.
With that being said, let me
show you how to enable it.
In the Cloud Console, click on
Billing, and choose the billing
account you want to work with.
You may have to click on
Manage Billing Accounts
first, then click on
Billing Export on the left.
Here's where you can see if the
billing exports for BigQuery,
or file exports, are enabled.
While there is an option to do
a CSV or JSON export under file
export, we don't actually
recommend doing this,
because it doesn't contain
as much information
as the BigQuery export.
The more information you
have, the more analysis
you'll be able to do.
So go ahead and click on Edit
Settings to choose a project,
and then choose a
BigQuery dataset.
If you don't have
any projects, you'll
need to create one
with BigQuery enabled,
then create a BigQuery dataset.
Creating a dataset is as easy
as going into the BigQuery
interface, clicking
on your project,
and clicking on the
Create Dataset button.
If you already have
a bunch of projects,
feel free to make a new one
just for this export or all
of the other cost management
efforts that you're working on.
Once you know which
project and dataset
you want to use, choose
them in the export settings
and hit Save.
You should see a
screen that looks
like this, which means
that you've successfully
enabled the export process.
You can click the dataset
name to jump into BigQuery,
but you probably won't
see anything yet.
It may take a few hours
to start seeing data,
since different services have
different update frequencies.
Also worth noting is that you
may incur some nominal BigQuery
costs for storing this data.
You can quickly
calculate any costs
by looking at the
BigQuery pricing page
and seeing how much
data you're generating
every day with the export.
You can also set a budget
specific to BigQuery
if you want to keep closer
track of your spending.
We'll cover this in more
detail in a later video.
Once the data starts showing up,
you can run queries against it
through the BigQuery UI.
Here's a sample query that
shows the amount spent
on each service by month since
BigQuery export was enabled.
This is a simple place
to start, but there
are lots of columns you can work
with, like Location, Project,
and Labels.
From here, you can
build and run queries
as you see fit to
analyze your data
or even start
making predictions.
Now, let's talk
about another way
to analyze your billing data,
creating a custom dashboard
with Data Studio.
Data Studio is an interactive
analytics tool built into GCP.
And it can integrate easily with
BigQuery to pull data and then
let you visualize it.
The quickest way to
set up a dashboard
is to start with the
sample billing report
that we've put together for
you as a starting point.
You can do this by visiting
the Sample Billing Report
and clicking the
How to Copy tab.
By following the steps
outlined on that page,
you'll set up some
special queries
and connect them to your
own copy of the billing
report in Data Studio.
This sample report is ready
to go, with charts and filters
to help you visualize your data.
On the Resources page,
you can filter by label.
So you'll easily be able to see
how your costs are broken down.
For example, if you chose
to label your resources
by environment, you
can see how much
you're spending on
production versus development
environments.
This is another reason
it's important to choose
naming conventions that are
clear and easily understood
by everyone.
You're also able to
build your own reports
by using Data Studio.
So I'll quickly
show you how to get
started with a basic report.
First, head to the
Data Studio page
and choose a blank report
to start from scratch.
Once it's been created,
look for the option
to Create New Data Source,
and then choose BigQuery.
From here, you just need
to select the same project
and dataset as well as the
table that BigQuery created.
After choosing it, click
Connect, and then click
Add to report.
Once the data source
is added to the report,
you'll be able to reference
it with different graphs
and filters.
As an example, you
can insert a new pie
chart that shows how much
you've spent on each service.
Click on Insert, and then Pie
Chart to add it to the report,
then click on it
to customize it.
By changing the Dimension to
service.description and then
the Metric to Cost,
you can quickly
see how your costs are split
between different services.
Different graphs have
different fields.
And you can create
interactive elements
to dynamically update them.
Exporting your data to BigQuery
lets you analyze your cost data
using BigQuery and SQL,
as well as setting you up
to visualize your costs with
Data Studio or other data
visualization tools.
In the next videos, we'll look
at advanced cost control tools,
like budgets and quotas.
[MUSIC PLAYING]